[Music]
Alexandria hilltop Kingdom our
communities have something in common we
all serve the Savior's we already
started this and we're gonna win
whatever it takes
together we can beat them we set things
right
of the times now join us and fighting
The Walking Dead returns this February
only on AMC
well we find the right stuff maybe we
don't need the numbers blow them up
barn into the ground he said that
weren't just soldiers with the Savior's
but there were workers there people
didn't have a choice got away we need
more hands another group you can has
outposts the geography the distance
works against us we got to get back and
come looking for Daryl we need to be
there you don't have to get back not yet
it's one of theirs
long range we can listen it keep track
of them so for not going by what are we
doing I think it's time I introduce you
to Ezekiel Kangas EQ okay
hey youtubers it's Charlie so new
Walking Dead footage let's break it down
march to war all-out war
I'll also address what's going on with
Chandler Riggs and Carl Grimes with the
time jump in season 8 and all that
craziness so there is a new round of the
walking dead giveaway that's going on
now all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on this
video be sure to click that Bell to
enable alerts so you don't miss anything
during the off season so let's start
with the footage first then I'll address
what's going on with Chandler Riggs
relationship with the walking dead
people it's not as dire as it sounds but
schedule they didn't say explicitly in
any of the promos but Walking Dead is
coming back February 12th so you can see
from these two clips it's really like
two promos jammed together is that
everybody's coming together but we have
to convince Ezekiel to get on board so
Jesus is going to introduce them Rick
and the survivors are gonna have some
fun kissing the ring and meeting Shiva
so most of the footage is just dedicated
to survivors going to the kingdom which
is probably where we're gonna Luke Carol
back in eventually but she had this big
kick in Episode eight about everyone
leaving her alone I don't want to have
anything to do with this the lady doth
protest too much
zekiel to bring the kingdom to fight
you're not understanding me I didn't
want you I didn't want a zekiel or
Morgan coming here and I don't want
anything to do with your lives where
you're dead I just want to be left alone
people will die a lot of them meaning
that she'll come back eventually - even
if she does stay in the kingdom she will
end up helping them somehow
the other wildcard in this situation is
you know you have all these people
coming together so you would think oh
okay wow this is gonna be pretty easy to
do they'll just get a bunch of help
they'll take negan down no if we've
learned anything from people coming
together on the walking dead tense
standoffs between villains and heroes
like in the season 4 midseason finale
with the governor in his tank some wild
card always brings rank goes off plan
yet everything blows up in everyone's
faces so they kind of tease the
survivors seeing a version of what we've
seen the kingdom do when they treat with
the Savior's the last time we saw this
scene Richard almost got in a fight with
one of the Savior's so even though he
was able to keep his cool
remember all those scenes in episode 8
where he started to lose his mind
trying to get Morgan and Carol to
convince Ezekiel to commit to a first
strike against negan and then he went
off and cried in his little trailer in
the woods so a lot of you were probably
like why are they dedicating so much
time to him crying in the woods by
himself in this weird trailer he's a big
character but why are we spending so
much time with him so it seems like what
they're doing is they're setting him up
is the wild card on the survivors the
kingdoms side so if there's any big
tense standoff if somebody's gonna go
rogue it's gonna be Richard who wants to
do the first strike the other big wild
card is Gregory at Hilltop who is the
biggest bag of dicks that they have
inside one of these places now that
Spencer is dead Spencer was a giant bag
of dicks Gregory is a giant bag of dicks
so they're under threat of anybody
turning against them with hopes of meat
you know maybe getting favorable
treatment or securing his leadership
it's Gregory running to fake negan or
Grand Theft Auto Trevor however you want
to think about him trying to tell them
what the survivors are trying to do
other meeting with the kingdom they're
trying to rally a force against you
so just remember Richard and Benjamin
are wildcards Gregory is a huge wildcard
we also see Grand Theft Auto Trevor come
back looking like he's going to be in
some sort of Grand Theft Auto scene with
Rick here driving down the road that is
gonna make so many
people happy and then think about the
Benjamin character we haven't seen him
in a while but they spent a lot of time
setting him up is like this innocent
young character that Ezekiel was trying
to watch over because it sounds like he
felt guilty that he got his father
killed so he kind of took it on himself
to take Benjamin under his wing sort of
like a really nice version of what you
kind of saw happening with negan and
Carl like negan was fascinated by Carl
but it was this really twisted psychotic
thing so you know Benjamin very innocent
character not a great soldier probably
close to the top of my list for
characters that are gonna die in the
back half of the season just because
they're teasing this crazy intensity
this build-up to all-out war and he is
just not a warrior at all and what
happens on The Walking Dead when the
[ __ ] hits the fan usually the people
that get killed are the innocent
bystandard it's like Olivia in episode 8
and then we got to talk about just like
this crazy Walker that Rick turns around
to see here it looks like some guillermo
del toro nightmare who just spikes
sticking out all over it so let me know
do you think that somebody dressed a
walker up like this after the fact or it
was a human with some armor on that then
died and fell on a bunch of spikes but
he kind of wonder how this could occur
naturally but I do like the way they try
to create new walkers each new season
like anytime there's a premiere or a
finale they usually try to have a couple
really cool Walker traps it's just a
couple really badass looking walkers but
let me know what do you guys think about
this promo what are you most excited
about when the show comes back I know
everybody's thinking about march to war
what's gonna end up happening at the end
of the season are they gonna do all-out
war there's still so much negan story to
be done even if you don't read the
comics they are kind of telegraphing
things here like they're coming together
but in no way is this going to go
smoothly like I said there's always a
wild-card somebody always goes rogue and
it all goes to [ __ ] and blows up in
everyone's faces that is why the season
for mid-season finale season 4 episode 8
is still one of my favorite mid-season
finales on The Walking Dead ever just
because the governor rolls up with the
tank Rick tries to get him to chill but
the governor isn't having it boom
beheads Hershel and it all starts to
blow up in their faces and goodbye
prison
it was one of the best ways that they
got rid of their old set gave them a
reason to go somewhere else so they
haven't really said how much longer
they're gonna stay at the safe zone they
could stay there for a lot longer but
supposedly there's gonna be a time jump
when we get to season 8 so hopefully
they'll blow up a couple more big places
by the end of the season so moving on to
Chandler Riggs Carl Grimes what the hell
is going on there been all these rumors
about him leaving the show to go to
college so what's happening in real life
is that the actor Chandler Riggs is
ended his seven-year contract that he
signed when he first came on to the
walking dead so his father posted the
celebratory notice like yeah you know
seven-year contract up were so happy
about this accomplishment we're so proud
of him you know bigger and better things
on the horizon just making it sound like
he was moving on from the show and was
just gonna go to other things so people
are like Carl Grimes is like a really
freakin huge character how are they
gonna address this is this a spoiler so
the internet went crazy he deleted that
post and then Chandler Riggs as well as
his mother came out and just said this
was just meant to celebrate the
seven-year contract being completed
Riggs said that he was excited to go to
college and was hoping that he would
continue his relationship with the
walking dead people so it sounds like
they'll continue to do Carl stuff but in
a diminished capacity which I think
everybody is fine with like if they're
not gonna do a lot of Carl storie it's
okay if he's not standing in every
single frame in the background just to
be there so Chandler Riggs the actor is
just really excited to do real kids
stuff go to college hang out with his
friends play video games but he doesn't
want to stop doing the walking dead but
just because of time constraints just
expect them to use less Carl in season 8
much less Carl in the time jump they did
say there'll be a time jump from the end
of season 7 to the beginning of season 8
they didn't say how much time would pass
but they just kind of fueled a lot of
the Carlile craziness because they're
like does that mean they need to recast
a version of Carl they're definitely
gonna have to recast Judith but I think
it's just them making a beeline for
whispers in the wake of all-out war but
I do think that all-out war just because
it's such a big comic book arc he's
gonna encompass the last little bit of
season 7 in the early part of season 8
like it's just
gonna be this long drawn-out craziness
then they can make room for the
whisperers to come on so what's gonna be
happening tonight is I'll post some new
flash and then I'll be posting a Star
Wars obi-wan Kenobi video before we get
started with rogue one craziness and I
will be doing a bunch of rogue one
videos later this week so make sure you
go see the movie when you have the
chance well you guys wait for that to
post you can click here for all my
Walking Dead videos and you can click
here to rewatch those spider-man
trailers thank you so much for watching
everybody let's high five I'll see you
guys tonight